John Dillinger was a different breed of
criminal he was a bank rubbing Pioneer
whose groundbreaking methods are still
used to this day this is a man who once
bluffed his way out of prison with a
pistol he' whittel from wood who robbed
actual police stations in order to stuck
up on supplies of guns and ammo and who
when things went South hired a rogue
plastic surgeon to alter his appearance
through the Strategic use of kangaroo
tendons and highly concentrated acid his
level of notoriety reached such dizzying
Heights that when when he met his
inevitably Grizzly end fans flocked to
the scene to dip their clothes in pools
of his
blood this is the remarkable story of
John Dillinger Public Enemy Number
[Music]
One